Hello world,
it's Saroj and automated trading.
Bots are a popular way to earn a passive
income and with so many tools available
on the internet, anyone can build
their own. In a few simple steps.
In this video I'll explain how to use a
reinforcement learning strategy called
cue learning to simultaneously predict
prices for three different stocks in a
portfolio using several data points.
If we look at finance industry reports,
we'll find that stock on and future
trading are all heavily automated and the
algorithms behind both trade execution
and optimization have yielded billions of
dollars for a few companies that invested
early on in machine learning in the
90s and early two thousands that means
that they've been working on this for up
to two decades now,
which is way before the deep learning
hype started in 2012 in fact,
AI in finance is perhaps the most
mature application of AI in any industry
setting and while lots of these companies
are very well funded so they can
afford the hardware necessary to
run machine learning algorithms,
the cost of hardware is following and
the accessibility of these algorithms is
increasing as open source culture.
It goes mainstream.
We can see this shift of activity move
into the realm of startups by browsing
the landing pages of companies like new
yoedicke.ai that offered traders and AI
system for back testing and daily
forecasting with automated trading.
Another example is Alpaca dot.
Ai got to love that name,
which creates a deep learning engine
that learns what your winning trades are
and then generates a unique
trading algorithm for you.
Based on that data alone,
you can even tune your algorithm
with sliders without using code.
There are so many data points we could
use that effect prices at different
scales.
News and rumors affect prices,
micro and macro economic cycles,
new laws,
but let's start simple.
Our starting data set
will be three CSV files.
Each contains stock prices
for the past 17 years for IBM,
Microsoft and Qualcomm prospectively.
The data set was created using the Alpha
vantage API that lets us access both
real time and historical stock data.
We'll want to build an algorithm
that can learn from this dataset.
Let's think about how
to frame this problem.
We have both historical data and access
to real time data via the API that can
constantly pipe in updated prices,
which we can add to our CSV files.
This is a real time environment
where time is a dimension.
We know then to use reinforcement as
it takes time into consideration using
reinforcement learning.
We can frame our problem as
a mark Haub decision process,
which consists of states' actions and
rewards are agent will be able to execute
an action in this environment.
And luckily for us,
the action space in this case is
pretty simple. For any given stock,
it can only perform three actions.
Buy,
sell or hold buy.
We'll buy as much stock as possible based
on current stock prices and the amount
of cash we have whilst sell.
We'll sell all shares of a stock and add
the generated cash to our cash balance.
If we're buying multiple stocks,
we would then equally distribute
the cash we have for each.
Hold on the other hand does nothing.
So the number of actions at any given
time step is three to the n where n is the
number of stocks in our portfolio.
Now at every time step,
our agent will be in a state and from
that state will make an action for our
state.
In this case,
let's consider it a combination
of the current stock price,
our account balance, and the number
of stocks we own. So, for example,
if we own 50 shares of IBM stock,
a hundred shares of Microsoft and 20
shares of Qualcomm and have $1,500 in our
balance,
we can represent our state as an array
which contains the amounts and prices of
each stock as well as the
total account balances we have.
So it's this state category of the MDP
that will contain any and all data that
our algorithm could learn from.
And we can add more to it later.
But let's start simply, if we simply plot
out the amount of capital we have four,
three times steps,
we'll see that the first two ideas for
our reward won't help the agent learn
from the difference in value
between each time step.
So we'll go with the third and this
exchange environment we've defined,
there are actually multiple agents,
meaning there are other traders with
their own respective account balances and
open limit orders that are
affecting prices. Unfortunately,
we don't have access to their data.
So we're dealing with a partially
observable Markov decision process.
And because it's partially observable
and we don't know what a full state looks
like,
we also don't know what either the
reward function or transition probability
looks like. Dynamic programming
is a technique that we use.
If we knew these two terms beforehand
to compute the optimal policy,
but since we don't know them beforehand,
we could instead use another model based
reinforcement learning technique to
learn these two functions.
Once we do that,
we'd be able to compute the optimal
policy because we'd eventually learn what
the effect is going to be of taking a
particular action in a particular state.
But what if we didn't need to
explicitly learn these two functions?
What if we could just learn the mapping
from states to actions directly?
We could compute a policy without
needing to construct a full model of our
environment model free
reinforcement learning.
That'd be much more computationally
efficient. So let's start with that.
Of all the model free techniques,
cue learning is the most
popular in cue learning.
We define a function to noted as Q of Sna.
This represents the maximum discounted
future reward when we perform an action
in state s and continue
optimally from that point on.
It's also called the
action value functions.
Since it measures the value of an action,
we can think of this function as the
highest possible account balance we can
have at the end of a training episode.
After performing action a in state s
it represents the quality of a certain
action in a given state.
In our case,
our possible actions are
either buy, sell, or hold.
Once we'd have this queue function,
it will rate all three.
Then we can just pick the action
that has the highest Q value.
So how do we compute this Q value?
We can express the Q value of state s
and action a in terms of the Q value of
the next state.
This is called the bellman equation.
It says that the maximum future reward
for this state and action is the
immediate reward plus the maximum
future reward for the next state.
The great thing about the bellman
equation is that it lets us represent the
value of a given state in terms
of the value of the next date.
It mathematically defines the
relationship between states,
which makes it possible for us
to approximate the Q function.
In the most simple case,
the Q function is implemented as a
table with states as rows and actions as
columns.
We'll initialize Q randomly then observed
the initial state s which is going to
be an array. Then we iteratively
compute the following four steps.
We select an execute an action,
then observed the reward and new state.
Using these three values.
We use the bellman equation
to update our Q function,
then set the current
state to the next state.
We just keep repeating that process for
as long as we want to set an episode for
based on just the data
we have given our model,
we can view the performance in this plot.
The red line is our initial investment
and the Green Line is the average after
2000 runs.
It looks like we made about 4,000
simulated dollars in a thousand days.
Notice though that the portfolio
values are very volatile,
which indicates the
instability of our agent.
So while that was a decent profit,
the variants is too high for us to
ignore that to longterm more data would
definitely help. We could add in
binary company news for each stock,
meaning positive or negative tweets.
We could also add in some company
performance metadata like market share,
growth rate, market
capitalization, profit margins,
et cetera.
So our state array would be much bigger,
encompassing many more values.
That would mean that our state
action space would be much larger,
so approximating our Q function
would take exponentially longer.
However, there exists an algorithm
that can approximate any function.
Can you guess what it
is? Yes. Neural networks.
If we use a neural network to
approximate the Q function,
we could then consider our
method deep cue learning,
and of course there are more advanced
are El techniques out there by policy
gradients, actor, critic, and
inverse reinforcement learning.
All of which I'll talk
about in future videos.
Three things to remember
from this video though,
a partially observable Mark Cobb decision
process is one where we don't know
what the true state looks like,
but we can observe a part of it.
A cute table is one where the states
are rows and actions are columns.
It helps us find the best
action to take for each state.
And Cue learning is the process of
learning what this cute table is directly
without needing to learn
either the transition,
probability or reward function.
Thanks for watching my video.
Please subscribe for more programming
videos and for now I've got to find the
cute table,
so thanks for watching.